Writing letters to Santa Claus just got a Web 2.0 upgrade this holiday season.
This is called "All I Want from Santa", it's an application.
Once you have your child registered, you create a wish list;...
...for instance, my son, he would like a remote-controlled monster truck.
You type in your wish list, you can alter it if you need to,...
...and then you can send it straight to Santa.
It's a new software application for your phone.
Users can let their children type in their wish lists...
...and go back to update them if necessary,...
...then mom or dad can send it on to Santa like a gift registry,...
...or children can type a letter to Santa in their own words if they want to.
Also, it has a countdown till Christmas, so I'm on the main screen, here you can see 24 days till Christmas.
Some parents say it could make their Christmas season a little easier,...
...but Santa says it's just a tool he's using.
It doesn't replace his one-on-one time with children.
Well, I doubt that it could because that can't create the interpersonal magic...
...that occurs when a child looks at Santa.
A doll.
A doll?
Each letter and list is archived, so the messages to Santa will be available long after the Christmas season ends.
Diane Kepley, the Associated Press.